what are you doing this we're exploring
this plantation
welcome ah dude and it's huge there's
like humid shits in a bedroom
mami enjoy his room whoo they're gonna
have sex there okay oh no wait
like maybe sorry sorry hey see you down
south longest let's do it
I follow you what are we doing we are
going into the abyss this
I can't see [ __ ] again what would you do
is like something just popped out would
you fight or flight
are you a flavor fight kind of guy
flight you're a flight the only room
that darkened yours
oh [ __ ] cool that's under they see
though cool there is AC team you play AC
as a purse of night and girlfriend it's
[ __ ] ice cold in here dude oh that's
why they get AC because into this room
they're feeding off your AC right there
oh yeah they could beat it feel it
through here oh you don't get the
jerk-off Brandon they can hear
everything you do in here you can eat
when a trace oh I could totally fit on
that boat if that happening I was
getting sex yeah he's gay see ya
Greg fair enough fair enough fair enough
not hungry sex what's over there would
you guys play uh we got too scared to
continue that's good no there's a bunch
of cars I think it's not a house
what what I got scared
wanna swim I gotta take a [ __ ] first ice
now why oh it feels good in here eh s do
they get to play their own porno this
might be the place where Bart and geo
see if their booty baby fairies made so
as you can see it's extremely humid here
in Hawaii and we're gonna go check out
what everyone's doing because everyone
is swimming it's 12 a.m. here in Hawaii
and everyone is taking a dip hello hello
hello everybody
why are we swimming yeah she just took a
shower yeah I just wish our I'm fed been
sitting here contemplating it for the
past like five minutes
really already what can I do big sticks
thing in there plug it up look at home
is our temple at DMI shotgun I can't
swim cuz I just dyed my hair yesterday
it's gonna turn green if I get in the
chlorine I have to wait until I get to
the Salton Sea all you wanted in color
anyway
spunky start with marine all right my
little star great right there's Casey
way over there socializing
the rest that one's Wayne this one there
and no that's plain
oh damn that's Wayne this is there
that's Wayne - oh [ __ ] Wayne hold on
that's Wayne this is Aaron Wayne and
Aaron which was weird and Wayne wear it
today you see Lou and plug in zero so
there's that house right there
that house right there and that house
right there this is the bail plantation
for their wedding morning today is
another beautiful day in Hawaii and we
have all gotten ready to go have an
adventure adventure time everyone's
already tucked away in the van
Marines looking confused check this out
waking up to this this is our backyard
can't get enough of this property this
property is amazingly beautiful really
go swim and eat and swim it eat and swim
and eat some more as I stay for lunch at
the beach oh yeah
I'm excited check out the beauty I swear
I must have said beautiful like a
thousand times during this trip alone
alright so after lunch we came to
shark's Cove don't worry there are no
sharks here he's calling that why make
it blend on oh my god you will not get
burned no chance to be nice
this place is probably my favorite place
the last time that we came because you
see a lot of fish here
damn we'll go swim
piece of art Nancy what is that it's a
pineapple slit it
and then you have no way
picking powder and it's 25 bucks don't
tilt it too much to fall over
I dare you I dare you
laughter
you guys are twins Easter Day
I want that one
oh yeah
welcome my not much press I will be your
host today
very ancient crane
miss Vicki
James drum a new arrival in Llanelli
mother oh yeah
so we stopped by to see this beautiful
sunset look at that gorgeous
and then there's downtown blue right
there oh my god it's so pretty
mother like a bottle butter
look at this girl log is everything in a
picture no no I forgot because his arms
down as I was trying to take a photo my
bad
when a wrong shirt this is not cheap
hell yeah come on Oh baby go buy a new
shirt Nick your blender yes make it
pretty but you know we're grown adults
we can bring real I already see the
commnd going crazy years old I think I
could have a beer coming out tonight
yeah
yes good
huh
I'll be in the issue
Thank You Shakespeare here